. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser Post-Breakfast-Folge. Schön, dass ihr da seid. Stefan Tietze ist da. Ich bin da, Florentin Will ist da, wir sind physisch anwesend. Wir sind physisch anwesend, aber unser Kalorienhaushalt ist durch die Decke, wir haben gerade ein richtig gutes Frühstück gegessen. Wir sind noch in New York zum Zeitpunkt dieser Folge, weil ich danach die Woche nochmal weg bin. Das heisst, da kann ich nicht aufnehmen. Deswegen machen wir hier jetzt noch die schöne Wrap it up New York Folge. Die Abschlussfolge, die wir legen uns auf den Rücken und strecken unseren dicken Bauch in die Sonne.
Bis wir dann aber auch los müssen und in den Flieger müssen.
Ja. Warum macht Essen eigentlich, also Essen ist ja Energie, warum macht Essen immer so träge danach?
Das ist die beste Idee.
Achso, ich war auf dem Gang, warum macht Essen immer so glücklich? Gut, du bist den anderen Weg gegangen.
Nee, warum macht Essen träge? Ich meine, das ist ja noch so aus dieser Mammutzeit, wo der Mensch einfach gesagt hat, wir haben unendlich viel Essen, weil ein Mammut riesengroß ist. Und dann fressen wir einfach so viel es geht und legen uns in die Sonne und machen gar nichts. Ist es nicht auch gut, dass man nach dem Essen nichts macht, damit der Körper das nicht verbrauchen muss, sondern direkt einfach in Fettreserven anlegen kann? Ja, das ist ja immer so das Ding. Es gibt ja Leute, die sagen, das ist eigentlich immer das Ding, also nahezu immer, das ist immer so die Sache, Leute die sagen, ja man soll danach einen Spaziergang machen, also sich bewegen. Nach dem Essen sollst du ruhen oder tausend Schritte gehen. Ja, das ist ein ganz merkwürdiges Sprichwort, aber. Nee, das heißt eigentlich, nach dem Essen sollst du ruhen oder tausend Schritte tun, was ich mir falsch fand, weil das richtige Wort, was dann käme, reint sich nicht darauf. Und dann sind Sprichwörter auch für den Arsch. Aber ich habe immer gehört, dass der Mensch, so wie wir ihn heute verstehen als soziales Tier, nur so entstanden konnte, weil das Mammut so dick ist. Hast du die Mammuts gesehen? Wir waren ja beide im Metropolitan Museum und im Naturhistorischen Museum, stimmt, und im Naturhistorischen Museum waren Mammuts ausgestellt, riesen Mammuts.
Das kann man sich nicht vorstellen. Wären die so Pudelgrösse gewesen oder sowas, hätten wir keine soziale Interaktion, weil der Mensch konnte es sich leisten, er hatte mehr Fleisch, als er braucht. Und dann sagt man mal, ja gut, dann machen wir mal ein Rentensystem oder so, dann kriegen irgendwie Alten, die nicht mehr arbeiten können, auch einen Teil des Mammuts ab oder ein Kindersystem, Kindergeld, Kindermammut, Fleisch oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Und so ist der Sozialstaat entstanden, weil man zu viel hatte.
Davor musste man immer jagen und dann irgendwie von der Speerspitze in den Bauch leben. Aber da ging es. Und deswegen danke nochmal rückwirkend von der gesamten Menschheit an das Mammut, dass ihr so riesengroße und flauschig seid. Flauschig seid und so kuschelig. Aber auch gefährlich. Oder waren die gefährlich? Haben die auch Jagd auf Menschen gemacht? Nee, weiß ich nicht, aber die hatten schon ordentliche Zähne und ordentliche Stoßstangen.
Brechstangen, meinst du?
Ich war dann im Naturhistorischen Museum und ich war so ein bisschen auf Podcast-Ufo-Mission, weil wir haben viele Fragen bekommen und uns selber schon aufgeworfen im Podcast bezüglich des leidigen Themas Tyrannosaurus Rex. Ach ja.
Dinos generell. War ein grosses Thema, haben uns oft begleitet, bis wir irgendwann davon Abstand genommen haben und gesagt haben, dass es so nicht weiter geht, wir haben da jetzt auch keine Lust mehr, uns zu informieren. Es geht bergab mit den Dinos, die haben jetzt Federn gehabt, manche hatten lustige Strohhüte, das kann uns auch nicht mehr irgendwie angehen. Lass uns von dem Thema distanzieren, dann haben wir uns auch lange davon distanziert und jetzt habe ich in New York halt die Möglichkeit gehabt, noch einmal mich mit dem Thema auseinanderzusetzen, ein bisschen was drüber zu lernen und dann vielleicht mich persönlich mit dem Thema zu versöhnen. Ja, es war tatsächlich so ein gewisser Leidensweg für Stefan Tietze und ich habe es auch gemerkt, als der Tag näher rückte, als du dann ins Natural History Museum gehen solltest, du wurdest nervöser, aufgeregter, für dich war das ein entscheidender Moment, glaube ich, jetzt zu sagen, okay, ich habe diese ganzen Fragen zum T-Rex und zu Dinosauriern, heute werden sie geklärt und es ist ein Scheideweg. Genau, genau, und wenn es jetzt dann, dann war es das vielleicht am Ende dieses Tages oder ich habe mich wieder mit versöhnt mit dem Thema, aber als Dino-Fan, finde ich, muss man dann auch noch mal zumindest einmal den Diskurs suchen und nicht davon weglaufen. Ja, das kann es ja auch nicht sein. Ich meine natürlich letzte Woche wieder gross in den Zeitungen T-Rex sexueller Missbrauchsskandal, da überlegt man sich, klar, darf man dann noch Fan sein, wie läuft das, irgendwie darf man Jurassic Park noch anschauen, darf man noch Dinos empfehlen, darf man seine Schleichdinge weiter verschenken. Richtig, die kleinen Hände tun nicht nur Gutes, das T-Rex. Ne, genau, ach Gott, ach ja. Die Bilder gehen einem nicht so schnell aus dem Kopf. Ich musste dann jedenfalls ins Naturhistorische Museum fahren. Er war schon sehr nervös und bin dann da in die Sonderausstellung zum Tyrannosaurus Rex, The Ultimate Predator. Sonderausstellung, ne? Also es gibt eine Sonderausstellung nur für den T-Rex, also perfektes Magnet. Genau, based on these new findings, based on die neuen wissenschaftlichen Ergebnisse.
Also genau das, was ich gesucht habe. Und bin dann direkt dahin gegangen, habe mich in die Schlange gestellt, habe mir andere viele nervöse Blicke geschaut, Gesichter geschaut. Man hat sich Blicke ausgetauscht, die sagen, ziehen wir es durch, jetzt gehen wir auch da rein. Dann angekommen, direkt der erste Schlag ins Gesicht. Es fing nämlich an mit dem Baby-T-Rex. Und das war so ein bisschen die Idee der Ausstellung, es ging darum, wie schnell der T-Rex im Laufe seines Lebens wächst. Die wurden so, sagen wir mal, 38 Jahre alt, T-Rexe, damals. Kurz vor der Midlife-Crisis dann auch gelassen. War es das dann auch. 38 Jahre war dann der natürliche Lebenszyklus, Zirkus, hätte ich was gesagt. Und tatsächlich war das eine der, bis heute ist es eines der Tiere, die unverscheinlich schnell wachsen. Das konnte man sich nicht erklären. Man hat Baby-T-Rexe gefunden und dachte erst, wie bei allen Sachen, die man mit den T-Rex gefunden hat, dachten die Forscher erst, das ist ein schlechter Scherz, das ist ein Baby-T-Rex, so groß wie... Paul, hast du wieder was vergraben bei uns? Also wirklich so groß wie so ein kleiner Hund, aber viel süsser, mit Schnabel... Die Wissenschaftler waren verwirrt, ob der Süssigkeit dieses Tiere, das zu süss.
Grosse Augen, komplett mit Federn bedeckt, ein Federkleid von oben bis unten und ein Schnabel mit kleinen Zähnchen. Also ein bisschen wie eine Ente, die aber längere Beine hat, also eine Ente, die nicht zum Schwimmen da ist, sondern zum Laufen. So ein Küken, ein grösseres Küken, unfassbar niedlich.
Und die haben das nicht zusammenbekommen.
Irgendwann haben sie uns gesagt, ja, haben sie es eingesehen, die nicht zum Schwimmen da ist, sondern zum Laufen. So ein Küken, ein grösseres Küken. Unfassbar niedlich. Und die haben das nicht zusammenbekommen. Irgendwann haben sie das eingesehen, die Wissenschaftler, und haben gesagt, also T-Rex-Forscher ist wirklich der schlechteste Job der Welt, du bist hinsichtlich nur enttäuscht. Du kommst da hin, du machst den Job ja, weil du den T-Rex cool findest, der T-Rex. Es ist dein Job, das, wovon du Fan bist, zu vernichten, eigentlich. Das ist dein ganzer Job. Das ist unfassbar. Je mehr, und irgendwann sagen die Leute, wir hören jetzt auf zu graben, einfach, es wird nicht besser, wir lassen es einfach dabei. Und diese Ausstellung hat auch versucht, das immer bedrohlich zu machen. Da haben die einen Projektor aufgestellt, dann war in der Mitte dieses Küken und rechts wurde dann so eine Silhouette fingiert von einem grossen Tyrannosaurus Rex, die man dann kennt, diese Silhouette aus Jurassic Park, wo man dachte, was versucht ihr hier gerade eigentlich, was welchen, woran, lasst den Stroheim los, an welchem Stroheim greift, haltet ihr euch gerade noch fest, das ist nicht The Ultimate Planet, wie auch die Ausstellung hieß, das ist ein Küken, das ist ein süses Küken, mit riesengroßen Augen, so wie eine Comicfigur, naja, gut, dann ging es weiter, alle waren da schon am Boden zerstört, die ersten sind schon rausgegangen, die Kinder sind dann teilweise schon einfach zurückgegangen, weil sie dachten, das halte ich nicht aus, was ich auch gut verstehe, ich habe das durchgehalten, bin weitergegangen.
Dann ging es weiter, die meisten Tiere aus der Tyrannosaurus-Familie waren nicht so groß wie der T-Rex, sind nicht so schnell gewachsen einfach, das ist einfach ein Tier, was enorm schnell gewachsen ist. Über 38 Jahre hat es dann irgendwann so das 500-fache Körpergewicht zugelegt und so weiter.
Und ja, dann irgendwann war die Ausstellung relativ ereignislos, bis es dann zum Endstadium kam. Und ja, man muss sagen, die Federn lassen irgendwann nach, das Federkleid lässt nach. Außer am Kopf, am Kopf bleiben Federn. Und zwar so wie so eine graue Haarpracht. Ich habe vorhin ein Foto gezeigt, ich habe es auch bei Instagram gepostet, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es noch mal das Herz bringe, das nochmal zu posten, aber es ist einfach eine graue Haarpracht. Es ist so ein mittellanges graues Haar. Es ist schwer, das jetzt natürlich als Podcast darzustellen, aber stellt euch vor, ein T-Rex mit einem Toupe.
Es ist relativ direkt ein Toupe.
Ich wollte das T-Wort nicht sagen. Es ist ein Haarfeld,
das auch irgendwie völlig
fehl am Platz wirkt und auch an der ganz,
also ein bisschen nach hinten gerutscht.
Wie nach hinten gegelt, so hinten gekämmt.
Es sieht aus wie ein schlecht sitzendes Toupe.
So ein bisschen so Sky-Dumont-artig.
Wenn Sky-Dumont längere Haare hätte, so nach hinten gemacht. Aber rechts und links fehlen die Haare auch komplett. Nur oben so ein ganz seltsam. Aber es sieht wirklich aus, wie man in der Kinderserie irgendwie so den weirden Onkel Dino machen würde, der einfach dann so komische, ein bisschen flausige Haare hat. Aber einfach, ich finde es so gut, dass sie einfach an genau derselben Stelle Haare haben wie ein Mensch Haare haben würde. Einfach so diese Kopfhaare, diese Frisur. Ich finde, sie haben ihm noch ein bisschen Würde gelassen, dadurch, dass sie die Haare nicht zu lang gemacht haben, weil man weiss natürlich nicht, wie lang die Haare, also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man genau weiss, wie die Frisur aussah. Und ich meine, er hätte einfach so wirklich so ein bisschen Ersatzlehrer Rex ausgesehen, wenn er einfach noch längere Haare hatte. Er sah aus wie der Vertretungslehrer, wenn er im Bio-Unterricht nochmal den Fernseher reinschiebt. Letzte Stunde vor den Ferien. Ja, ja. Och, Herr Rex. Ja. Och, es ist wirklich... Also da hat man einem König beim Sterben zugeschaut. Ich poste das nochmal auf Twitter unter der Folge, damit das alle sehen können, weil dieses Bild ist wirklich gerade... Und auch dieser hilflose Blick von diesem T-Rex, der einfach... Man kennt den T-Rex ja immer so von unten, so mit dieser, der Boden vibriert und er kommt von unten und brüllt, aber ich weiß schon, warum die den von unten zeigen, weil von oben, da sieht es einfach, sag ich mal, sieht es einfach nicht gut gepflegt aus. Und dann gab es auch so ein Experiment, weil man hat herausgefunden, der ging nicht so, wie man das denkt. Also wenn man sich den ganzen T-Rex in der Silhouette vorstellt, stellt man sich den immer vor,, wie er aufrecht geht so ein bisschen. Oben diese hilflosen kleinen Arme, das vielleicht noch mehr, und dann unten der Schwanz. Ein bisschen wie Godzilla, stellt man sich den ja vor, gehend. Nee, nee, nee, der Schwanz ist nämlich so lang, dass der Oberkörper den ausgeglichen haben muss. Das heißt, er ging fast waagerecht. Das heißt, der war, du als Mensch guckst über den Dino hinweg. Der ging ja fast waag fast. Ach so, weil der so fast schlängelt eigentlich. Ja genau, der hat seinen Kopf so nach vorne gereckt. Ja, so ein bisschen so Superman-Pose eigentlich. Ja genau, die ganze Zeit so, ich schwebe-Pose. Und die Analyse der Hüftknochen hat ergeben, dass er wahrscheinlich keinen normalen Gang hatte, sondern eher sowas wie ein Hoppserlauf. Tänzeln. Also eher so links, links, links, rechts und so. Und ja, das ist leider die Knochen, Leute. Sorry. Dann kam raus, der wiegt nämlich sechs Tonnen und man hat dann Versuche durchgeführt, Gehversuche, wie er gegangen ist und hat dann festgestellt, der kann nicht rennen. Der konnte nicht rennen. Wie, der kann nicht rennen? Er konnte nicht rennen. Nur weil der ein bisschen schwerer ist. weiss es doch nicht, dass er nicht rennen kann. Nein, der ist so schwer, dass immer ein Fuß auf dem Boden sein muss. Das heißt, er kann keine Flugphase haben, was du fürs Rennen brauchst. Das heißt, er konnte nur gehen. Und deswegen war der so gross, weil er sonst… Er konnte nur bummeln eigentlich. Ja, er konnte flanieren. Er konnte nicht rennen, er konnte nicht sausen. Ja. flitzen ging noch, aber sausen nicht mehr. Gar nicht mehr, er konnte einfach nur ein bisschen schneller gehen dann, wenn er wütend war oder weggerannt ist. Spazieren, er konnte spazieren. Er konnte spazieren, er war ein Spaziergänger und er war nur, weil er so einen grossen Kiefer hatte, aber du musst dir vorstellen, der ist rumgegangen und hat halt die Dinge aufgefressen, die gerade zufällig in seinem Weg waren. Er konnte jetzt nicht Dingen hinterherlaufen, niemals. Wie, aber er war doch Jäger, war doch Raubdino. Ich wollte das jetzt nicht von mir aus ansprechen, aber nein, er hat halt gefressen, was im Weg war. Wie, er hat gefressen, was im Weg war? Wie gesagt, er konnte halt nicht rennen, alle Tiere waren schneller als der T-Rex. Ja, aber der ist doch gross. Ja, er ist gross, manchmal läuft ihm was ins Gesicht. Ja, aber ein grosses Tier, das bummelt, ist ungefähr so schnell wie ein kleines Tier, das weht. Es ist ein bisschen schneller, aber die kleinen Tiere hat es nicht bekommen. Mal, wenn er halt von der richtigen Seite kam und zufällig einer in seinen Mund gefallen ist. Zufällig wäre man, der eine geht die Treppe hoch und der andere kommt um die Ecke und dann so, woop, oh und dann kann er ihn schnanappen. Tatsächlich haben die gesagt, dieser Ankylosaurus ist der mit der grossen Keule hinten am Schwanz, der gepanzert ist und so. Den hätten die theoretisch, also die fliehen dann nicht. Der einzige, der nicht kriegt. Ja, die fliehen dann nicht. Und man sieht sie schon so auf dem Horizont und dann so, oh nö, oder so ein Spazierverfolgungszimmer. Ja genau, es ist super langsam, er versucht wegzulaufen. Nee, weil dieser Ankylosaurus, der läuft halt nicht weg, weil er sich verteidigen will mit so einer Keule und so. Und dann kann der T-Rex aber gezielt angreifen. Und dann konnte man so ein Quiz machen, da waren immer so Quizze für Kinder. Und die Quizfrage war, was du machen würdest, wenn du jetzt der T-Rex wärst. Du bist jetzt Timo oder T-Rex, würdest du den Ankylosaurus angreifen, weglaufen oder mal gucken, was passiert? Und ich natürlich mit allem, was ich gelernt habe bei der Ausstellung, gesagt, weglaufen, nicht, dass der Ankylosaurus so angreift. Dein Selbstbewusstsein für den T-Rex hat sich komplett gedreht. Nicht, dass meine Haarpracht irgendwie noch zerstört wird oder sowas, das soll halt schön bleiben. Und das Mädchen vor mir hat dann aber eingegeben, nee, angreifen. Und tatsächlich hat man, da stand dann irgendwie, ja, du bist ein gefährlicher Räuber. Natürlich greifst du den Ankylosaurus an. Und ich so, nicht an dieser Ausstellung hat mir gesagt, dass ich ein gefährlicher Räuber bin, okay, sorry. Naja, und genau, er konnte nicht rennen. Dann, die kleinen Arme, auch ein Riesenproblem für die Wissenschaftler damals, die haben dann diese kleinen Ärmchen gefunden und die dachten, sie hätten einen behinderten Dino, Dinoskehle, also einen behinderten T-Rex ausgegraben. Nichts hat die glauben lassen, okay, das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt die Regel. Und es war wieder so ein tiefer Schlag ins Gesicht der Dino-Forschung und dann irgendwann kam raus, das sind tatsächlich die richtigen Händchen und Ärmchen.
Die Geschichte des T-Rex ist gespickt mit vielen Momenten von Pressekonferenzen, wenn man sagt, ja, also es stellt sich jetzt doch aus, es ist der T-Rex und wir haben diese... Das Publikum immer ...
Nee, es ...
Leute, wie gross waren die Arme?
Ja, so halt ...
Zwanzig ... Ne, es ... Leute, wie gross waren die Arme? Ja, so halt 20 Zentimeter. Ja. Und manche Wissenschaftler behaupten, dass er dann einen Leichnam hochgenommen hat, einen Kadaver, und dann hat er mit diesem kleinen Ärmchen den aufkratzen können, um ihn dann wieder hinzulegen und den aufgekratzten Körper besser zu essen.
Aber ganz kurz, was haben die Arme denn gemacht, während er läuft? Weil bei Menschen hast du ja, also da läuft ja der ganze Körper eigentlich so, da machen die Arme so. Das fällt hier in New York auf. Viele Menschen, und man schlenkelt sich ja auch durch Menschenmassen durch, der Mensch rudert, vor allem dicke Menschen. Die haben oft dann dicke Frauen, die beobachtet, weil die in die in einer Hand die Handtasche haben und in der anderen Hand so ausholende Bewegungen mit dem Arm machen, um irgendwie den Körper im Gleichgewicht zu halten. Das will ich zum Beispiel in einem Museum sehen, wie ist der Mensch damals gelaufen und dann so eine ausholende Ruderbewegung mit dem linken Arm haben und wie oft ich geschlagen wurde einfach von so einer Frau einfach in den Magengrube, bei mir ist der Schritt dann auf der Höhe, was schon nervt.
Ey, was ich sehr oft im Gesicht hatte, waren Zeigefinger, waren, ich glaube, wir müssen nach da hinten, ausgestreckter Arm, Zeigefinger im Times Square und ich krieg's einfach direkt ins Auge. Daran erkennt man auch New York-Touristen. Alter! Wenn man eine Woche in New York war, erkennt man die an dem komischen Akzent, den die beibehalten, am American Accent, you know, und die roten Punkte im Gesicht, der gekommen ist, weil da ist aus Empire, sorry, da ist Empire State Bank. Furchtbar, aber haben die T-Rex-Ärmchen nicht so mitgejoggt? Du meinst so wandern, die Wandergesten. Also so angewinkelt wie beim Rennen so ein bisschen, oder hingen die einfach runter? Und die hatten auch nur zwei Klauen, die hatten auch nur zwei Klauen, die hat die ganze Zeit dieses Peace-Zeichen gemacht. Also es ist der Vertretungslehrer, machen wir uns nichts vor, es ist der Vertretungsbiolehrer. Ich sage mal, es könnte noch schlimmer sein, sei froh, dass er überhaupt Ärmchen hat. Ich glaube, er wäre wesentlich lächerlicher, wenn er einfach nur aus zwei Beinen und einem Maul bestehen würde, einfach wie so eine grosse Kaulquappe. Es ist einfach ernüchternd gewesen. Aber vor allem, wo geht das noch hin? Ich meine, wenn die Forschung bis jetzt so falsch lag, wo kann das noch hingehen? Irgendwann stellt sich heraus, ja, er ist eigentlich eher ein Fisch als ein Vogel. Und er kam, also er hat diesen dummen, dusseligen Gesichtsausdruck. Und er hat sich diese Blume ins Haar gesteckt, weil die Fressopfer anlockt. Wir dachten erst, es sei eine Blume, die zufällig beim Pfund daneben lag, aber wir haben diese Blume bei jedem T-Rex gefunden.
Auch hinter den Ohren gefunden.
Wir müssen leider mittlerweile davon ausgehen, dass sie das getragen haben.
Genau, um halt Opfer anzulocken, weil dieser Duft dieser Pflanze, der hat sich Blume ins Haar gesteckt.
Und eigentlich dachten wir, dass es irgendwie so römische Überreste seien, weil wir so eine Gürtelschnalle gefunden haben, aber es sieht so aus, als hätte der T-Rex tatsächlich einen Gürtel getragen. Ja, es tut uns leid, die Wissenschaft diktiert leider hier Objektivität. Und die Jeansweste? Korinthischer Ursprung, da ist noch viel zu forschen, ja? Also das nicht! Regionswessel? Das nicht! Das könnte alles sein! Gott! Ja, okay, also von mir aus war es das mit dem Dino-Thema. Ich meine, immerhin haben sie dieses Jahr noch versucht, die PR aufrechtzuerhalten, wenn sie sagen, wenn die Ausstellung hieß irgendwie The Greatest Predator Live. nächstes Jahr dann die Ultimate Joke, wo man einfach es komplett kippt und man sagt, Leute, ja, jetzt macht euch einfach lustig und alle lachen sich kaputt. Und dann haben sie hinten so ein Videoscreen gehabt, wo dann Kinder davor standen und dann kam der Dino angelaufen, um die Kinder zu erstrecken, das ist ja so ein Geisterbahnelement. Kein Kind war erschreckt, weil man Angst hatte, dass dieser Vertrauenslehrer-Typ aus dem Gebüsch hervorspringt.
Ja, dass er wieder so ein Aufklärungsvideo zeigt, das wir alle schon mal gesehen haben und den Mädels zuzwinkern bei den heißen Szenen.
Es war weniger so ein Kind, der hat Angst, dass die Eltern ziehen, das Kind besorgt weg.
Ja, das ist so sücht.
Es war nicht so Angst, dass der Dino dieses Kind frisst, sondern dass der Dino sich vergeht an denen. Ja, ja, genau. Weil er diese Haare hatte und diese Jeansweste. Naja, das war die Tyrannosaurus Rex. Ich meine, wir leben in einer Zeit, in der Helden fallen. Also viele Leute, die zu denen wir aufschauen, stellen sich als... Louis C.K. ist gefallen. Nicht die raus, die wir dachten, dass sie sind. Max Landis ist gefallen. Max Landis ist gefallen. Und jetzt ist auch noch der T-Rex gefallen. Und der T-Rex ist gefallen. Also welche Helden, auf welche Helden kann man sich eigentlich noch verlassen? Ich habe keine Antwort darauf, ich weiß es nicht, ich traue mich nicht. Aber wir haben Judd Apatow gesehen. Wir haben tatsächlich Judd Apatow gesehen. Im Comedy Cellar, beim Comedy Cellar ist es sehr oft so, dass man nicht weiss, wer manchmal reinkommt, weil manchmal auch einfach sehr prominente Leute da noch noch reinschneiden. Und bei uns war es Judd Apatow, der Director von Superbad zum Beispiel. Genau, und der Director-Visuer? Kann sein. Achso. Weiss ich auch nicht. Auf jeden Fall ein grossartiger Produzent, hat auch die tolle Serie Love auf Netflix gemacht, Crashing mit Pete Holmes, macht jetzt einen Film mit dem tollen Pete Davidson, also wirklich ein Comedy-Genie. Ja. Auch ein Stand-Up- auf Netflix, ich hätte fast gesagt ein gutes, aber ist gar nicht so gut. Das ist immer mehr produzierende Drehungen und so, aber das macht er ja toll. Aber sein Stand-Up war lustig, also war so ein Dad-Humor, so ein sehr gesettelter, dickbäuchiger, ruhiger Mensch, der dann, wir waren am Fourth of July abends da, wo wir dachten, wenn wir jemanden sehen wollen, den man kennt im Comedy-Seller, dann sollten wir nicht am Fourth of July hingehen, aber dann haben wir da Joe Deppet-Talk. Aber sein erster Gag war so ein bisschen, ja, hast du Fourth of July, auch so wie ich, wir verstecken uns hier im Keller. Aber interessant, Fourth of July, ich würde sagen, eher unspektakulär für uns, weil wir auch keine Ahnung haben, wir waren auf dem Dach und haben zwei Böller gesehen und das war es dann auch. Aber na ja, es ist wie gesagt schwer, den Charakter und die Eigenheiten von so einem Feiertag zu verstehen, wenn man damit nicht aufgewachsen ist, glaube ich. Ich glaube, man kann Böller kaufen, ich glaube, man trifft sich abends. Du hast uns aufgeregt gefragt, wie feiert man den 4. Juli, was ist das für ein Feiertag? Ich glaube, es ist Silvesterartig, nicht nur wegen des Feuerbergs abends, sondern auch, wenn man sich da trifft und in die Nacht reinfeiert. Ja, bei Silvester gibt es einen Countdown, da kann man, okay, ich verstehe, irgendwann gibt es einen Countdown und da gibt es einen Moment. Bei Silvester feierst du ja nicht einen Tag, sondern einen genauen Moment und dann halt ein paar Stunden davor und ein paar Stunden danach. Aber bei Fourth of July ist dann so, ah. Du feierst das Feuerwerk so ein bisschen und davor hast du ein paar Stunden Grillen und danach hast du ein paar Stunden Musik hören und trinken. Aber ja, wir haben das letzte Mal mehr mitbekommen, diesmal waren wir in der U-Bahn, als das Feuerwerk war. Man muss halt Prioritäten setzen. Wir haben uns ferngehalten von allen anderen. Wir haben unfassbar viel gesehen. Also wir haben zusammen gerechnet drei Theaterstücke gesehen und drei Musicals. Ich habe zwei Theaterstücke gesehen, du hast drei Theaterstücke gesehen.
Ich habe mir noch, ich dachte, wenn man schon mal hier ist, habe ich mir noch eine Karte gekauft.
Es gab nur noch eine Karte, leider, für Cursed Child, das Harry Potter Stück.
Und lustigerweise, ich dachte immer, das wäre ein Stück.
Nee, es sind ja zwei Stücke.
Und zwar läuft das meistens dann so ab, dass du mittags um 14 Uhr den ersten Teil schaust, der geht dann drei Stunden mit Pause dazwischen, dann hast du ein paar Stunden Zeit und abends gehst du dann in den zweiten Teil und das finde ich ganz seltsam. Ich wusste, ist das in Deutschland auch so, wenn man ins Theater geht, dass man dann zwei Stücke guckt oder zwei Abende oder was?
Wer tut sich das an? Man kann einen Trailer online sehen von diesem Theaterstück und es ist natürlich wie alles auf dem Broadway super krass inszeniert mit Pyrotechnik und fliegenden Büchern und allem super krass. Aber als du gesagt hast, hey, lass uns in Harry Potter gehen, war ich so, na, als du dann gesagt hast, es gibt leider nur noch ein Ticket, da dachte ich dann, na, dann nimmst du, Stefan. Ja, du warst sehr schnell überzeugt. Ich war sehr schnell davon überzeugt. Wurde er so großzügig, habe ich gesagt,, dann gehen wir beide nicht. Nee, dann soll niemand das haben. Stefan, du willst das sehen, du hörst schon den ganzen Morgen den Harry Potter Soundtrack. Das war ein Zufall. Du hast deinen Schlafanzug an, mit Herminen drauf. Der war gerade gewaschen. Du kannst da ruhig hingehen. Und dann habe ich das geschaut und es war echt ernüchternd. Das Buch habe ich damals auch gelesen und es war schon kacke, weil es die ganze Zeit um diese Time-Turner geht, diese, wo man sagt, das ist doch die beschwellten Idee. Das uninteressanteste Element der Harry-Potter-Welt. Naja, in Teil drei war es cool. Ja, es war cool für einen Moment und wenn man lange darüber nachdenkt, irgendwann sieht man sich, aber okay. Und die brechen hier alle Regeln. Das Coole ist ja, also Zeitreisengeschichten machen ja selten Sinn. Und es gibt ein tolles YouTube-Video auch über Zeitreisengeschichten und
die kommen zu solchen Konklusiven wie ich,
dass Harry Potter Teil 3 mit
die coolste Zeitreisengeschichte ist,
weil es ein tolles System aufbaut,
diesen geschlossenen Loop, dieses
wenn man zurückreist und was macht, ist es
auch schon damals passiert, als man zum ersten Mal
da war, diese Loops.
Das fand ich ganz toll. Ich finde das bescheuert,
bei Back to the Future zum Beispiel,
ist ein toller Film, aber dass du das Bild anschaust und dann verschwindet da jemand im Hintergrund, aber alle anderen stehen noch genauso, das ist halt einfach bescheuert, also ist halt nicht so nachvollziehbar. Also kann man die Vergangenheit manipulieren oder nicht? Bei Harry Potter kann man es nicht. Da ist es eher determiniert und sie merken, oh, wir müssen jetzt das tun, was wir in der Zukunft schon getan haben werden. Es gibt diese wahrscheinlichkeits-, diese baumartigen Verläufe mit du machst neue Timelines auf, dann gibt es den Back to the Future Weg, du machst eine neue Timeline auf, aber alle anderen existieren auch nicht, sondern es gibt einfach dann eine neue und bei Harry Potter ist halt dieser geschlossene Loop und dem widersprechen die ja auch. Nicht nur geht es die ganze Zeit um die Geschichte, die wir schon gesehen haben, in den ersten sieben Filmen, beziehungsweise in den ersten Büchern, acht Filmen und in den ersten sieben Büchern, sondern es geht auch die ganze Zeit um diese Timeturner, wie sie dem System widersprechen, was J.K. Rowling eher in Teil drei aufmacht. Weil du jetzt plötzlich auch verschiedene Realitäten hast und so und nicht schon die ganze Zeit das. Sie wollen die Vergangenheit verändern. Es wird die Vergangenheit tausendmal verändern. Die Effekte waren ganz toll und das war fantastisch mit den Pyrotechniken und es waren ja teilweise so magische Effekte und so weiter und Leute sind verschwunden und woanders aufgetaucht. Keine Ahnung, wie das geht, unfassbar toll, was da an der Effektfront passiert ist, aber die Story ist einfach so grauenhaft und die Jokes sind so schlecht gewesen. Und es war wirklich eine ganz, ganz, ganz schlechte Erfahrung. Aber trotzdem bin ich froh, es noch gemacht zu haben. Und die Musik die ganze Zeit. Nee, gar nicht, gar nicht. Die Musik war die ganze Zeit so eine moderne Remix-Version. Unser Abi-Stück damals war ja auch Harry Potter. Das habe ich damals mit einem Kumpel geschrieben, unser Parodiestück für Abi Potter, genau. Und wir haben die ganze Zeit nach Musik gesucht, die haben so eine moderne Remix-Version, die es kostenlos bei Soundcloud gab, von dem Harry Potter Soundtrack genommen, weil man die nutzen konnte kostenlos.
Und das war ganz cool, damals war so Dubstep-Version von den Harry Potter Soundtracks, war ganz cool damals für ein Abistück, für die Umabhausen.
Aber genau das haben die jetzt genommen bei dem richtigen Stück.
Auch dann, weil wir so eine Liebessene im Hintergrund, die ganze Zeit so ein Mellow-Beat. Ganz absurde Entscheidung. Das heißt, du hast dich auch auf deinen Abi-Ball zurückversetzt gefühlt. Es war für mich eine grosse Abi-Ball mit besseren Effekten und besseren Bühnenbildern. Furchtbar. Werbung. Für euch, wir haben einen Code für euch, wo ihr alle Premium-Features eine Woche lang ohne Abo-Verpflichtungen einfach testen könnt. Wow, wie meine ich das? Ganz einfach, gebt ihr den Premium-Code try-live-now, gebt ihr ein in den App-Einstellungen deines Profils, einfach unter Einstellungen, da könnt ihr dann unter Einladungscode diesen Code eingeben, habt dann eine Woche das ganze volle LeVu-Paket. Und die App selbst ist natürlich auch kostenlos, die könnt ihr euch downloaden, wo auch immer ihr eure Apps downloadet. Genau, richtig. Auch toll ist das neue Streaming-Feature. Du kannst einfach Livestreamen, anderen Zuschauern, Geschenke hin und her senden und dich einfach leicht unterhalten lassen und gleichzeitig neue Leute kennenlernen. Toll, ich muss unbedingt mal wieder neue Leute kennenlernen. Kannst du auch Geld verdienen damit. Aber jetzt löst du erstmal den Code ein und dann schauen wir weiter. Try Live Now? Try minus Live minus Now. Viel Spaß mit LeVue. Jetzt geht's weiter. Tschüss.
Werbung Ja, aber ansonsten haben wir viel Tolles gesehen. Wir haben das Stück mit Adam Driver, war wirklich fantastisch, Burn This heisst das, wo es um nicht viel ging, einfach nur um einen Todesfall und die Leute dann nachher mit der Tower umgehen in einem New Yorker Loft. wirklich fantastisch gespielt und Adam Driver will ich mal so zwei Stunden bei der Arbeit zuzugucken, live, ist schon wirklich unfassbar. Auch die anderen Cast-Member waren alle toll. Krasser Typ. Man weiss halt nur nicht mal den Namen, weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr. Ich war viel im Metropolitan Museum, habe mir viele alte Sachen angeschaut, war sehr interessant, habe leider keine Führung mitbekommen, aber habe mir die ganzen alten Rüstungen angeschaut und die alten Waffen und die ganzen Tode, Waffen und alles. Ich auch, und kam ja auch aus Deutschland dann oft. Nürnberg. Ich glaube, nirgendwo kann man sich so stolz fühlen, Deutscher zu sein, wie in der Rüstung-Ausstellung des Metropolitan Museums, weil immer heißt der legendäre Nürnberger Rüstungsschmied und man so, da war ich auch schon mal. Ja, Nürnberger, ich komme aus der Nähe, ich komme aus der Gruppe der Nähe. Warst du schon mal in Nürnberg? Nein. Ja, aber ich habe schon mal davon gehört.
Lustigerweise gab es ja einen krassen Rückruf, Heiko Lochner oder sowas.
Heino Lochner, irgendwie so hieß der.
Lochner, glaube ich jedenfalls.
Und der hat damals wohl irgendwie dann diese Rüstung gebaut und hatte internationale Reparationen.
Und den hat man dann immer gefragt.
Und der hat auch wohl international ja einfach Aufträge bekommen.
Das heißt, auch von den Franzosen und von den Engländern musste Heiko Lochner dann die Rüstungen machen. Das heißt auf dem Schlachtfeld standen sich dann zwei Ritter in jeweils Lochner Rüstungen aus. In so einer schnicken Lochner, wo auch beiden so Lochner stand oben. Ja ja. Da musst du aber bitte keinen Kratzer reinmachen. Ja. Die war echt teuer und die muss sich immer nach Deutschland schicken, um die zu reparieren. Guck mal, haben Sie auch eine Lochner? Ah ja. Das ist ja schick. Haben Sie die denn, Herr? Bonjour, bonjourno. Ach, haben Sie auch einen Lochner, Herr Franzose? Oui, oui. Ja, dann, na ja, ist die Claro. Gut, dann, a passé. Ja, also das war, das Metropole-Museum ist immer wieder toll. Aber es ist auch verrückt, weil, also im Ganzen check ich's nicht, weil weil es heißt ja, die Leute waren damals kleiner, weil die Rüstungen sind ja relativ klein. Also es ist natürlich schwierig, das einzuschätzen, weil die sind ja nicht ganz hauteng, aber schon relativ am Körper gebaut, die wurden ja auch massgeschneidert, wenn es eine teure Rüstung ist, aber die wirken schon sehr klein und das heißt ja auch immer, und auch wenn du so römische Legionäre siehst oder sowas, die sind echt ein gutes Stück kleiner. Ich kann mir nur nicht, also es heisst ja auch, dass es an der Ernährung lag, dass wir uns heute viel, naja, nicht besser, aber wesentlich nahrhafter oder mehr Kalorien einfach zu uns nehmen und alles einfach mehr wächst vom ersten Jahr an. Aber es ist schon weird, weil es ist ja nicht mal 500 Jahre her, dass die echt so ein gutes Stück kleiner waren einfach. Das ist schon echt merkwürdig. Wenn man denen so gegenüberstehen und sich denkt so, warum bist du so klein? Auch hier wieder, um auf den Zeitreisefilmen zurückzukommen, würde ich gerne mal eine Komödie sehen, einen Zeitreisenfilm, der einfach einen krassen Realitätsanspruch hat, wo man dann zurückreist und dann waren die alle einfach gut drei Köpfe kleiner. Und ich sehe ja aus wie große Trottel. Ich wäre wahrscheinlich so eine Art Troll für die... Oder so eine Art Gott dann. Nee, eher Troll wahrscheinlich. Ja, oder ein Gott-Troll, kannst du eine neue Religion aufmachen. Also einfach so, wow. Ja, wahrscheinlich wäre ich einfach so wie dieser bei Game of Thrones, der Mountain oder der krassen Typ. Ja, und der ist schon interessant, vor allem diese ganze Idee des Verzierens ist ja mittlerweile komplett weg.
Also der hat dann irgendwie auch so die Gewehre oder so und die waren ja wirklich mit winzigen, ganz miniaturenhaften Gemälden und dann Geschichten erzählt. Und heute verziert man gar nichts mehr, selbst wenn man irgendwie super reiche, teure Sachen kauft, nichts ist verziert. Das ist halt alles minimalistisch, aber jetzt ein super teures Auto, wer respektive im Mittelalter halt dann ganz fein graviert, mit ganz vielen Namen und der eine
hatte einen Kalender auf seinem Gewehr, einen kompletten Kalender, wurde halt da eingraviert,
irgendwie dann so mit so Säure so eingeätzt oder so, hat einfach einen Kalender und einfach so,
welcher Tag ist heute? Der Tag zu sterben, für den Gag hast du vier deiner Sklaven verkauft. Aber es ist schon merkwürdig, weil ich weiß nicht, ob das wiederkommt. Weil gerade wenn man in so einem Geschichtsmuseum ist, dann merkt man ja schon, dass gewisse Dinge immer wieder wiederkommen. Zum Beispiel auch so teilweise so Teller. Es sehen teilweise sehr modern aus, weil die irgendwann auch wieder sehr minimalistisch waren. Dann irgendwie so in dieser Wiener Zeit oder so, wo dann nur ein blauer Kreis außenrum war, gab es dann irgendwo so eine Zeit, wo man sich denkt, genau den Teller kann man auch bei Ikea kaufen. Also es kommt wieder, ich frage mich, ob dieses Verzieren nochmal kommt, weil wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel Mikrofone, die sind ja teuer und die sind ja auch technische Geräte, aber die sind überhaupt nicht verziert. Die sind nicht irgendwann wieder verziert.
Kommt das wieder?
Ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Ich hätte es schon.
Dass dann da so kleine Noten drauf sind und dann so der Heilige, der Podcaster oder sowas.
Gibt es eigentlich schon einen Podcaster-Heiligen?
Ich glaube, Nils Buckelberg und Tim Pridler.
Und Mark Maron sind, glaube ich, zwei. So eine Dreiheiligkeit dann einfach. Ja, das Dreigestirn. Ja, das Dreigestirn. Den finde ich gar nicht so uninteressant. Ich glaube schon, dass es, aber gerade kommen eher so die 80er, 70er, wieder 90er. Man guckte gerade sehr in die junge Vergangenheit, aber ich finde auch gut, man sollte mal wieder in den Barock zurück. Stimmt, wird der Kreis immer kleiner? Ja, bis man irgendwann nur noch das trägt, was gestern auch schon modern ist. Das stimmt, dann immer gestern, heute, gestern, heute und man ist dann immer in so einem immer kleiner werdenden Kreis. Zwei T-Shirts im Schrank, man weiß auch nicht genau. Ja, ich weiß es nicht, das ist eine interessante Frage. Ich finde es auch toll, da gab es diese Schränke mit Gewehren und also so lange Waffen. Ich weiß nicht, was da der richtige Ausdruck für ist.
Jedenfalls gab es dann da Vitrinen, die deutschen, die spanischen, die französischen und die englischen und die holländischen. Und ich hätte vorher wetten können, dass wenn man mir die Waffen zeigt, ich sagen kann, aus welchem Land die kommen. Weil die klischeehaft, das was man selber von, also die Spanischen, die hatten halt unten, wie man das kennt von diesen Flut der Karibik Filmen, die Spanier hatten halt so spanische Waffen, unten mit diesem Knäuel dran an den Waffen, dann hatten die halt diese, wie man das kennt aus spanischen Restaurants oder wenn man mal in Mexiko war oder so wieder die Wände verziert sind, die hatten halt diesen südländischen Flair einfach, wogegen die Deutschen halt sehr rustikal, eckig, weltlich waren. Und das fand ich total interessant, man hat das den Waffen meiner Meinung nach angesehen, woher sie kommen. Das ist interessant. Die Klischee-Waffen waren das. Ich meine, heute ist halt auch alles krass vernetzt, da ist irgendwie dann, hast du so eine AK-47, die wird in der ganzen Welt verwendet und damals, glaube ich, wurde es nicht so ganz stark verbreitet, da haben halt dann die Deutschen wirklich nur deutsche Waffen gehabt und dadurch hast du dann auch so abgrenzende Stile, heute ist es ein bisschen mehr vermischt, aber interessant, bin sehr gespannt, was die Zukunft bringen wird. Ja, das ... Vielleicht sind wir irgendwann so ein Sound-Pfeil in so einem Museum, wo man dann sagt, so dachten die Trottel damals, dass es weitergeht.
Und haben die sich über den Klimawandel Gedanken gemacht? Nö, die haben über einen T-Rex geredet, der vor mehreren Millionen Jahren gelebt hat. Stimmt, war Klimawandel bei uns ein Thema schon mal eigentlich? Ich glaube, mit Scham auf so einen Podcast zurückgucken. Ja, das kann schon sein. Ja, das ist dann genau wie in der Nazizeit, wo es dann hieß, niemand wusste davon und bei uns immer so, nö, wir wussten es schon, aber wir haben halt, war halt nicht so das Thema.
Ehrlich gesagt hat mich der New York-Urlaub hier ein bisschen aufgerüttelt, was die Klimawandel angeht, glaube ich, weil ich merke, wie wütend mich das hier macht. Also das ist ganz unironisch. Und du fliegst dann aber morgen direkt weiter nach?
Ich flieg weiter nach Bologna direkt.
Aber tatsächlich, man hat mich das unironisch wütend gemacht und man sollte auch Flüge, wenn man die auch ausgleichen damit, gibt es ja gewisse Dienste und so weiter, das werde ich auch jetzt machen. Aber dieser Move im Supermarkt, ungefragt einem fünf Plastiktüten in die Hand zu drücken, ist einfach ein vermeidbares Problem. Dieses Plastiktütenproblem hier in New York ist unglaublich. Aber du kriegst so viele, ich weiss nicht warum die diese, also die machen vielleicht die Plastiktüten ganz dünn, damit man nicht so viel Plastik verwendet, aber dafür kriegst du halt immer direkt fünf. Wenn du eine Wasserflasche kaufst, die würde sofort durch eine durchreißen, weil die super dünn ist. Und du hast einen Rucksack auf, ich hab einen Rucksack auf und alles an mir sagt, ich brauche jetzt keine Tüten und dann habe ich auch immer gesagt, nee, ich will dir keine Tüten. Und dann schmeißen die mich wieder weg.
Das ist echt vermeidbar. Und dann diese riesen LKWs, die nicht nur laut sind, diese alten Trucks, die man einfach kennt aus so Route 66 Road Movies. Diese grossen Dinge mit den riesen Schornsteinschloten vorne obendrauf, die schwarze Wolken hinter sich herziehen und unglaublich laut sind und unzeitgemäss. zeit das ist alles falsch, das ist alles falsch. Und ich muss sagen... Ich freue mich über jeden DHL-Truck, der hier mit Strom rumfährt. Amerika hat viele tolle Dinge gemacht, waren auf dem Mond, toll, gut gemacht. Wissen wir das? Aber, wo ich überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen kann, warum sich das durchgesetzt hat in Amerika, sind die Toiletten. Es gibt ja sehr unterschiedliche Toiletten-Designs und die amerikanischen sind ja mit Wasser gefüllt, also da ist die Hälfte der Schüssel mit Wasser gefüllt. Also wir haben ja oft so dieses kleine Loch, irgendwie wo dann Wasser drin ist, aber der Grossteil ist eher trocken. Und den Präsentierteller haben wir auch. Und wir haben den Präsentierteller, ja der ist klassisch deutsch, aber die Amerikaner haben ja wirklich Floating, da floated alles drin und das ist ja das maximal dümmste, was man überhaupt machen kann. Also auf gepflegten Klos ist mir eigentlich egal, auf ungepflegten Klos ist es das widerlichste der Welt. Ja, weil es ist oft so gerade in so Museen oder in Theatern oder so, da hast du dann so eine Reihe Pissoirs, aber dann auch die Kabinen und selbst wenn du, sag ich mal, eher das Pissoir hättest verwenden sollen, gehst du dann trotzdem in die Kabine und stehst halt dann, machen viele. Und das ist ja das absolute Todesurteil, wenn das ja mit Randvoll und mit Wasser gefüllt ist. Da geht ja alles überall hin, wenn es da rein plätschert. Absolut katastrophal. Und mich hat es auch ein bisschen wütend gemacht, im Museum, wie respektlos die Leute mit dem Museum als solchen umgehen. Die stehen da vor wirklich jahrtausende alten ägyptischen Sarkophagen, sind super laut, rennen da rum und dann schaust du dir, dann hast du keine Ahnung, in der Kunstabteilung schaust dir dann irgendwie einen Edward Hopper an und denkst dir, okay krass, Stern der menschlichen Schaffenskraft und gehst auf die Toilette, wo die Leute einfach das Klopapier auf den Boden werfen, einfach in der Kabine, einfach auf den Boden. Mein Kunstwerk! Und dann denkst du, Leute, ein bisschen, ein bisschen zivilisatorisch an Anstand, wo einfach dieser Kontrast zu gross ist, aber ja, ich weiß nicht, warum sich das durchsetzt, aber wahrscheinlich auch so wie dieses Meilen und Inchding, das kriegst du halt einfach nicht mehr weg. Das ist halt so... Wir haben ein bisschen Feedback bekommen, dass ich ja, die Frau im Central Park, die uns gefragt hat, wo das Tor ist, und ich habe, als wäre es das Normalste der Welt Welt gesagt, just a few meters in that direction, und da kam ein Feedback zurück, dass wir bis heute noch das Tor suchen, weil sie nicht wissen, was Meter sind, aber ich hätte auch bei bestem Willen nicht gewusst, was ich denn sagen soll. Yards? Ja, ich glaube Yards. Aber ich glaube, es gibt ja so eine Strömung. Just like a thousand inches in that direction, I have no clue. Couple of feet, just a stone throw. Twenty feet. Aber ein Yard ist ungefähr ein Meter. Nee, Yard, nein. Ein Yard sind ungefähr so 20 Meter, wie man sagt. Ach so, weil zum Beispiel bei Football sagt man dann wieder Yard, da sagt man dann wieder nicht feet, es ist super strange. Aber es gibt ja auch so eine Bewegung in Amerika, die, sage ich mal, bewusst das metrische System verwenden. Oh doch, du hast recht, jahr das sind meter viele viele wissenschaftler auch oder so die dann halt bewusst immer millimeter und meter sagen oder so und es kann ja auch sein dass es sich vielleicht ändert da gibt es ja eine große bewegung aber natürlich auch im museum oft auch die metrische angabe ja ja genau habe ich auch genau mitbekommen so klingenlänge oder so. Ich glaube, in so wissenschaftlichen Kreisen hat es sich vielleicht schon durchgesetzt, in Amerika.
Man muss halt auch mal teilen, New York ist halt ultra progressiv. Ich glaube, wenn du jetzt selbst in einem wissenschaftlichen Institut irgendwie im Midwest bist, ist es vielleicht auch anders. Aber vielleicht gibt es da eine Möglichkeit, dass es geändert wird. Ich meine, Amerika ist in so vielen Dingen so ähnlich, aber teilweise so kleine Sachen sind einfach anders.
Türen zum Beispiel. Ich sehe an jeder, wenn ich in einen Laden reingehe, was bestelle, habe ich dann so kleine Probleme immer, wenn Rückfragen kommen, weil die sich keine Mühe geben. Ich glaube, wenn man so gut Englisch spricht, dass man nicht sofort, weil die immer andauernd Ausländer die Sprachen neu lernen. Ich glaube, wir sprechen zu gut Englisch, als dass sie sich noch Mühe geben, langsam zu sprechen. Und das sind einfach, wenn man die nicht weiss, was für Fragen dann kommen, beim Burrito bestellen. Kauft niemals ein Burrito, das ist immer eine komische Situation. Man versteht alles falsch, wenn da ich einen ganz komischen Burrito, obwohl ich eigentlich gut Englisch spreche, aber es hat für den Burrito nicht gereicht. Und dann gehen die Karten nicht, die deutschen Sparkassenkarten und dann geht man raus und will die Tür einfach aufmachen, aber die Tür hat keine erkennbare Richtung, weil du hast nicht diese Klinke, diese deutsche Klinke, die sind halt so anders die Türen und ich erkenne immer nicht, ob man das schieben muss oder nicht und dann drücke ich immer auf der falschen Seite und dann kommt jemand da rein und drückt mir die Töne ins Gesicht. Man sieht manchmal aus wie der letzte Vollidiot. Man hat auch keine Chance. Ich glaube, das ist auch so eine Instinktsache. Es ist wirklich so eine Instinktsache. Und was mir auch aufgefallen ist, es gibt ja glaube ich so Instinkte, die hat der Mensch vor Jahrtausenden von Jahren gelernt irgendwie, dann irgendwie, wofürür die Fressen, Hilfe der Tiger greift an, was muss ich tun?
Aber ich glaube, es gibt auch moderne Instinkte, zum Beispiel Steckdosen finden in einem Raum. Das ist ein, da hat jeder intuitiv, also angenommen, du bist in einem Raum und du musst sagen, wo sind die Steckdosen und man kann intuitiv sagen, wo sie wahrscheinlich sind, einfach weil man es natürlich gelernt hat und so. Aber auch dieser Instinkt verlässt einen komplett in Amerika, was einem dann erstmal auffällt, weil nicht da Steckdosen sind, wo man es erwarten würde oft. Und weniger Steckdosen. Und weniger Steckdosen. Aber ich glaube, das ist so etwas ganz Spezielles. Oder zum Beispiel Toiletten in Restaurants. Ich glaube, das ist ein menschlicher Instinkt, der mittlerweile so ein kultureller Instinkt, dass wenn du, du weißt immer schon grob, wo die sind. Oder wenn du sagst, hier nicht, aber in Deutschland habe ich immer das Gefühl, ich komme ganz gut hin. Ich sage so, ich denke, wo sind die und ohne zu wissen, wo sie sind, gehe ich in irgendeine Richtung, gehe in irgendeine Ecke und da sind sie dann meistens auch. Einfach weil man es schon so ein bisschen im... Genau wie ich in einem Five Guys war auf Toilette und den ich gefunden habe zunächst und dann bin ich eine Treppe hochgegangen, weil das der Instinkt ist, über die Treppe hochzugehen, weil meistens irgendwo anders der Klo dann ist, wenn es zwei Stockwerke gibt. Und oben war dann so eine andere Bar, aber außerdem nicht so eine Szene, eine Szenebar. Ich weiß nicht, wo ich dann da gelandet bin, die mich auch alle angeguckt haben, ihre Gespräche eingestellt, und dann bin ich irgendwie entschuldig und wieder runtergegangen und dann habe ich die Typen gefragt, wo ist das Klo hier? da oben, war schon richtig. Und dann war da diese parallelen Welt über dem Five Guys, so ein dreckiger Five Guys, oben war dann so eine Szene-Kneipe, keine Ahnung, da gab es doch keinen anderen Aufgang für die. Die teilen sich dann, zwei Läden teilen sich eine Toilette danach. Genau, wahrscheinlich ja, auch Eingang wahrscheinlich, ich glaube nicht, dass die noch einen eigenen Eingang hatten, diese Bar, da muss man einfach, aber auch super schick trotzdem. Das war schon auch seltsam.
Naja, aber so Kleinigkeiten sind ja einfach anders. Das fällt dann schon immer noch auf.
Heute fliegen wir zurück.
Heute fliegen wir zurück. Wir sind schon eingecheckt, wir sind schon bereit. Die Sachen sind noch nicht gepackt, das machen wir gleich im Anschluss.
Hast du Packstrategien?
Ich habe ja immer einen grossen Müllsack dabei. Ich bin ja mittlerweile komplett auf Müllsäcke umgestiegen, was meine Organisation angeht.
Gut, dass wir gerade noch gesagt haben, weg von Plastik. Ja, die sind aber kompostierbar, habe ich extra geguckt bei meinen Kaufen. Und vielleicht heisst es auch was anderes, Comprehensible, keine Ahnung. Verständlich. Ich stecke alles in einen grossen Müllsack und den Müllsack in meine Tasche und das war's. Warum den Müllsack? Damit, dass die dreckigen Sachen bei den dreckigen Sachen sind. Du willst nicht, dass da irgendwie... Das darfst du dich nicht vermischen mit meinen Comics, die ich gekauft habe. Aber hast du nicht aus einer Woche alles angezogen? Nee, überhaupt nicht. Nee? Nee. Du hast doch drei Shirts. Ja, nee, jetzt habe ich ein paar mehr, weil ich habe tatsächlich ein bisschen, muss ich tatsächlich zugeben, ein bisschen zu viel Bargeld abgehoben und deswegen war ich dann gerade gestern, im letzten Tag, so ein bisschen in so einem ungesunden Kaufrausch, weil ich einfach Geld vernichten musste und habe mir dann zwei T-Shirts gekauft, eine von Katz Delikatessen und eine vom Comedy Seller. Also freut euch, liebe Moin Moin Zuschauer, ich habe bald wieder mehr T-Shirts. Ihr müsst nicht immer wieder dieselben sehen. Ich habe wieder ein paar neue. Mal schauen. Ja, wir haben jetzt genau, gestern war es bei Katz Pastrami. Toll. Ja, das ist so ein ganz alter, sehr, sehr bekannter Laden, wo man so riesengroße Sandwiches bekommt. Aber was heißt Sandwiches? Es ist ein Stück Brot und dann einfach 16 Schichten Pastrami und dann nochmal Brot umdrauf. Pastrami ist sehr schwer zu erklären. Es ist so eine Art Pökelfleisch, glaube ich. aber ich weiss noch nicht genau, was Pökelfleisch ist, aber es ist so eine Art warmes Schnittrindfleisch mit einer Gewürz... liest euch den Wikipedia-Tag, keine Ahnung. Aber interessant, und die haben ganz legendärerweise so eine Aktion gehabt während dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, dass man den amerikanischen Soldaten in Frankreich und Europa eine Salami schicken kann. Sente Salami. Ja. An die Front einfach. Du konntest deinen Freunden, Verwandten an die Front eine Salami schicken. Ganz fantastisch. Ja, ich habe vergessen, wie dieser Spruch heisst, weil irgendwas reimt sich da. Sente Salami. Ich glaube, das war der Spruch. Und die Telefonn ist 1 801 Hotdog. Obwohl ich nicht verstanden habe, ob man einem bestimmten Soldaten die Salami schicken kann, also angenommen, dein Sohn ist im Krieg, kannst du dem bestimmten Soldaten eine Salami schicken oder spendest du einfach generell eine Salami an die Army und die verteilt die dann, wie auch immer. Das weiß ich nicht. Konnte mir auch niemand beantworten. Also aufgefragt die Frage. Ja, ich habe die Waiter gefragt. Ja, das weiß ich auch nicht genau. Aber auf jeden Fall eine gute Aktion. Aber falls ihr mal eine schnelle Antwort braucht, warum hat Deutschland den Zweiten Weltkrieg verloren? Weil die Amerikaner Salamis hatten. Ohne Ende. Und die wurden alle von Katz Delikatessen aus New York gespendet. Die Deutschen hatten Panzerschokolade. Ja, stimmt.
Crystal Meth.
Ja.
Mein Opa hatte auch Crystal Meth genommen, sehr viel.
Habe ich im Nachhinein erst erfahren, weil ich habe dann irgendwann am Familientisch Weihnachten mal von Panzerschokolade erzählt, was niemand kannte.
Und ich habe denen erzählt, was es ist, dass es immer Crystal Meth war.
Und dann kamen so nach und nach meine Verwandten ins Reden und haben dann gesagt, ja Opa hat immer damals von Panzerschokolade erzählt, wie toll das war und dass er es gerne mal wieder nehmen würde, essen würde. War dein Opa im Krieg aktiv? Ja, der hat diesen Funkwagen gefahren, war aber auch in Russland zum Beispiel und ist dann auch da in Gefangenschaft geraten und ist dann zurückgetrampt von Russland, am Arsch der Welt nach Moskau, weil ihm das dann nach drei Fluchtversuchen alleine gelungen ist, zu fliehen. Krass, lebt er noch? Nee, und der hat Panzerschokolade geliebt über alles und auch andauernd genommen im Krieg. Ich weiß nicht genau, war das wirklich Schokolade angereichert mit Crystal Meth, was sie aber nicht wussten? Das kann schon sein, das weiß ich nicht.
Aber ich glaube, die haben schon irgendwann gemerkt, die haben, ich glaube, denen wurden schon gesagt, ja, nehmt das mal, wenn ihr nicht mehr könnt oder sowas.
Ich glaube, man hat nicht versucht, das als Schokolade zu tarnen. Aber schon krass, ich glaube, das war ja gerade am Anfang 1940, als die Frankreich angegriffen haben durch die Ardennes oder so, da mussten die einige Tage wirklich durchgehend.
Handgeschöpft in den Hermann Göring-Schokolade-Werken. Ja, und das ist tatsächlich eine interessante Geschichte, die Wehrmacht und Drogen, auch einfach so krass, dass man das einfach einsetzt und einfach sagt, das wahrscheinlich auch … Das war unsere Salami an der Front, also unsere im Sinne von … Ja, ja, nee, aber auch einfach, dass man sagt so, ja, es gibt hier ein Problem, der Mensch muss irgendwann schlafen, ja, wir haben hier chemische Mittel, die das einfach aushebeln. So was von Kaffee gehört? Ja. Tessin Kaffee, aber wir waren gerade in so einem richtig schönen amerikanischen Diner, haben da gefrühstückt. Und der Kaffee hat genau so geschmeckt, wie man es aus dem Film erwartet. Wenn da so eine dicke Waitress sagt, darfst du noch ein Tessin sein, Schätzchen? Mit so ganz hohen Absätzen, ja. Komm, gib mir noch ein Tesschen, Süße. Moment, sagt sie selber? Nee, ruft der andere, der in der Bar sitzt schon länger. Fill me up, Honey. Fill me up, Honey. Dorothy, Dorothy, Honey. Und dann ruft die immer so ein paar Sachen hinter den Counter. Dann bestellt man irgendwie ein Scramble Eggs und ruft sie immer was Besonderes. Ja. Meistens nie Scramble Eggs. Die haben ihre eigene Sprache. Die haben ihre eigene Sprache. Das ist schon faszinierend. Genau so ein schönes Liner war das. Werde ich vermissen auf jeden Fall. Ja, das war New York, eine Woche New York. Wir haben gestern Fantastisch Impro gesehen, als grosse Improfans.
UCB-ASCAD-Klassiker, grossartig.
Genau, die Upright Citizens Brigade, die seit Jahren für tolle Improvisationskomite steht. Und gestern haben wir deren Flagship-Show ASCAD gesehen, wo ich immer das Gefühl habe, da sind kaum Touristen. Und ich bin kein Fan von Orten, die touristisch sind, im Urlaub schon gar nicht. Aber wie cool es wäre, wenn da mal mehr Leute hingehen, auch wenn ihr aus Deutschland kommt und Bock habt auf eine richtig tolle Comedy, dann schaut euch mal eine Improvshow an. Ja, Asked auf jeden Fall, UCB hat generell wahnsinnig viele Shows, auch richtig coole Shows, so eine Talkshow mit jemandem, der George Lucas spielt, schon langem, oder Improvisite Seinfeld folgen und so, also wahnsinnig viele coole Sachen. Wir hätten eigentlich auch mehr angucken müssen, aber wir haben ganz viele andere Sachen gemacht, ganz viele Musicals angeschaut, zum Beispiel Hamilton. Hamilton! Hamilton! My name is Alexander Hamilton. Super. Ja, hat grossen Spaß gemacht. Also ich kannte es schon natürlich schon gut davor, weil ich es jahrelang gehört habe, immer wieder. Ja, ich auch. Aber es hat dann schon echt Spaß gemacht und der englische König war grossartig. Ja, also tolles Musical, muss man schon sagen. Ich war ein bisschen nicht enttäuscht, aber es wurde halt seit drei Jahren mir empfohlen von allen Menschen. Deswegen weiß ich nicht, meine Erwartungen waren halt, glaube ich, unübertrefflich in der Hinsicht und ich weiß nicht, ob ich deshalb so ein bisschen so eine Ernüchterung eingesetzt habe, ja, ist einfach ein Musical.
Damals hat Book of Mormon zum Beispiel, hat mich mehr weggehauen damals, also so auf der Comedy-Ebene und die Story und so. Und auch Hades Town, was wir gesehen haben, das ganze neue Musical, kann man auch nur empfehlen, fand ich auch auf einem ähnlichen Level, komischerweise. Aber gut, war trotzdem fantastisch. Ja. Und dann haben wir, was haben wir noch gesehen, das Theaterstück mit Aaron Sorkin, To Kill a Mockingbird. Klassiker. Ein Klassiker, wo man ja, der auch ganz toll war. Also da fährt man nach New York, Leute. Fliegt man nach New York, zerstört das Klima, jetzt ist es noch akzeptabel. Ich glaube, ganz im Ernst, in fünf Jahren wirst du
zum sozialen Außenseiter, wenn du fliegst.
Ja, kann sein.
Also ich glaube, das fängt jetzt schon so ein bisschen an,
aber wenn du wirklich sagst, ich bin geflogen,
sagen die Leute ja mit dir, also vielleicht jetzt nicht so,
mit dir will ich nichts mehr zu tun haben,
aber ich glaube, es wird immer, also auf der einen
Seite, was ich sagen will, ist, fliegt
jetzt noch so viel, wie es geht,
auf der anderen Seite,
aber ich glaube,
es wird schon ein Wandel sein, vielleicht sind wir
Die Auf der einen Seite, was ich sagen will, ist, fliegt jetzt noch so viel, wie es geht. Auf der anderen Seite... Darf man mich nicht im Distanzieren von diesem Flugzeug?
Aber ich glaube, es wird schon ein Wandel sein.
Vielleicht sind wir die letzte Generation, für die Fliegen relativ normal war.
Weil ich weiß nicht, wie es mit Elektroflugzeugen aussieht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man da Fortschritte macht.
Ich höre da relativ wenig davon.
Elektromobilität am Boden, ganz gross.
Aber das ist ja auch genau die Sache.
Ich glaube, dass Elektromobilität auch nicht die Lösung ist, sondern die Energieerzeugung, die Stromerzeugung ja auch ein Riesending ist. Ja, klar. Da hat ja auch mal ausgerechnet, dass ein Test dann nicht unbedingt umweltschonender ist, weil die Energie, die verbraucht wird. Aber die Idee ist ja dann, auf regenerative Energie umzusteigen. Ja, genau. Wie gesagt, da hängen ja auch dann noch Entscheidungen dran. Also ich glaube,, da muss einfach eine Menge passieren. Aber vielleicht wird der Flugverkehr wirklich mehr oder weniger eingestellt, wenn es keine Alternativen gibt, aber da arbeiten kluge Leute bestimmt dran oder irgendwie Elon Musk mit seiner Röhre. Aber das ist schon lustig, da ist auch wirklich eine Wende gerade im Gange, weil es immer die Idee war, schneller, wir wollen schneller ans Ziel, wir wollen schneller dahin, machen Zü schneller, mach die Flüge schneller, aber seit Jahren ist der Trend tatsächlich jetzt schon,
das ist aber auch nicht so lange, aber jetzt schon ein paar Jahre,
energiesparender. Mich ärgert aber ein bisschen, dass Flugzeuge immer noch so langsam sind.
Ich meine, die sind seit 100 Jahren ungefähr gleich schnell.
Es wird, glaube ich, nicht geforscht in Richtung, wir machen es schneller.
Ja, aber auch mal der nächste Schritt. Jetzt kommen Flugzeuge seit 100 Jahren und es ist auch mal gut, die haben wir jetzt durch. Jetzt muss irgendwie das nächste kommen, weil immer dieses acht Stunden lang nach Amerika, das ist ja ewig lang. Das ist ja, also entweder es gibt noch irgendwas schnelleres oder man geht wieder zurück zu einer Welt, in der man einfach zu Hause bleibt oder in seinem eigenen Land oder in dem Land, wo man aufgewachsen ist, weil Reisen einfach entweder zu teuer oder zu umständlich oder was auch immer wird.
Ja, kann man mir gut vorstellen, dass es die Konsequenz daraus ist. Schon wachrüttelnd hier Amerika, fand ich sehr interessant. Hier fällt es schon auf, dass es noch ein bisschen, hier gibt es auf jeden Fall Aufholbedarf. In Deutschland merkt man das manchmal gar nicht so doll, weil da schon relativ viel gemacht wird. Also hier in Deutschland bin ich nicht andauernd damit konfrontiert, bewusst konfrontiert, hier läuft was falsch. Ja, da habe ich in Deutschland nicht das Gefühl. Sollte man auch häufiger mal haben, wahrscheinlich, wenn man mal wieder eine Plastiktüte sieht oder keine Ahnung, Leute, die zu viel mit Auto fahren oder sowas. Aber da setzt es nicht bewusst ein bei mir der Gedanke, dass wir verloren sind. Hier in New York, an jeder Ecke. Es wird sehr deutlich, dass wir verloren sind. Allein auch gestern war Müllabholtag und die ganze Stadt hat gestunken, weil alle plötzlich, gestern war, was war jetzt noch für ein Tag, Sonntag, okay, dann ist es noch schon Sonntag der Mülltag. Und alle haben ihre riesen Garbages genommen und und es ist ja sau warm draußen auf die Strasse geworfen, auf den heissen Asphalt und überall stand so qualmender Müll rum. Ich weiss auch nicht, warum diese Mülltüten schwarz sind. Ist das nicht die schlechtest mögliche Farbe für Mülltüten, weil dadurch werden die noch heisser. Ich weiss nicht, wie viel dieses Plastik aushält, wenn es wirklich die Sonne drauf ballert, wie blöd. Unangenehm und die ganze Stadt hat gestunken, wirklich bestialisch gestunken. Ja. Naja. Wir fliegen zurück, ich kann es noch gar nicht glauben, bald sind wir wieder zurück in Deutschland und kehren wieder zurück zu unserem normalen Alltag. Ja, also war wieder eine coole Zeit, viel Erfahrung gesammelt, aber ich muss auch erstmal reichen mit unserem New York-Quatsche. Nächste Woche setzt dann wieder Normalität ein und wir reden wieder über die guten alten Sachen. Du bist erstmal nochmal schön in Bologna unterwegs. Ja genau, aber das senden wir ja in der Woche. Bisschen Vino. Ich bin in Florenz tatsächlich, fliegt nach Bologna und dann wieder nach Florenz. Du machst nochmal einfach schön Entspannung, einfach mal schön Hängematte. Ich will nochmal den Urlaub vom Urlaub machen jetzt, halt gesagt. Also ihr werdet viele Bilder von mir sehen, wie ich im Pool im Weinberg schwimme. Trinkst du schön Wein? Ja, manchmal schon ganz gerne. Einen roten? Lieber weiss. Ja? Ja. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Tatsächlich merke ich, dass vielleicht irgendwas in mir würde gerne anfangen, Alkohol zu trinken. Ich merke das vor allem dadurch, dass ich viele Dokus anschaue, zum Beispiel Schnepse, ich habe jetzt ziemlich viele Dokus über Schnepse gelaufen, Jägermeister natürlich auch, früher auch als Göring-Schnaps bekannt tatsächlich. Echt jetzt? Ja, aber vor allem, weil Göring der Chef der Jagd und Forst und so was war. Und der Schokoladenmanufaktur. Und der Erfinder und Besitzer der Jägermeister aber tatsächlich da nicht so viel Bock drauf hatte, also muss man das differenziert betrachten, aber auch letztens Wein-Doku angeschaut und irgendwie so Sangria-Doku und alles so, ich bin da drin, aber ich mag's nicht, trink's nicht. Es ist so der Disconnect zwischen ich würde es gerne mögen, aber mein Körper sagt nein, genau wie Sport. Also bei Weinen habe ich jetzt zum ersten Mal so ein bisschen über die, habe ich in den letzten zwei Jahren glaube ich angefangen das mal zu entdecken oder sowas.
In den letzten Jahren wahrscheinlich eher. Vor zwei Jahren habe ich fast keinen Alkohol getrunken, fällt mir gerade immer so auf. Aber dann kam die Serie irgendwann und dann hatte ich so viel Stress, dass ich abends immer was getrunken habe. Ja? Ja. Bist du ein bisschen Alkoholiker geworden? Nicht Alkoholiker, aber ich habe jeden Abend was getrunken, so zum Runterkommen, was dann auch nicht gut ist. Und da war ich dann auch extrem schnell, habe ich dann derdolp zugenommen, weil Alkohol den Stoffwechsel verlangsamt und du hast auch dann Hunger bekommst dadurch, das ist ganz, ganz schlecht, das sollte man auf gar keinen Fall machen. Aber da habe ich das so ein bisschen dann, zumindest Wein kennengelernt und so. Und in einem gewissen Mass ist das auch schön. Ich glaube, ein Glas Wein in der Woche ist auch super gesund. Aber da kann man viel entdecken. Das ist auf jeden Fall so eine coole neue Welt. Auf der anderen Seite käme ich auch nicht genug dazu aus, um noch was zu erzählen drüber und bin mittlerweile wieder sehr gut davon los. Aber so Stressphasen sind teilweise, man macht dumme Sachen. Was ich für mich entdeckt habe, sind Vitamintabletten. Klar kriege ich jetzt bestimmt 100 Males, die sind schlecht und die ersetzen keine Ernährung. Weiß ich alles, müsste ich ja gar nicht machen. Aber ich mag sie einfach, weil ich mag dieses Brause, ich mag dieses Knistern. Und ich finde einfach, es ist so interessant, dass es davon 20 verschiedene Sorten gibt. Und dann eine mit Calcium, eine mit Eisen, eine mit Selen, eine mit Vitamin C. Und ich denke immer so, für wen ist das gedacht? Wer hat einen solchen detaillierten Überblick über seinen Vitaminhaushalt? Klar, wenn du irgendeine Krankheit hast oder zum Beispiel Veganer, nehmen B12, weil man das irgendwie schwer ersetzen kann. Wenn du viel Sport machst, machst du ein bisschen Magnesium. Sowas, aber ansonsten auch die Sachen, die ich noch nie gehört habe in meinem Leben. Und dann einfach denke ich mir immer so, warum gibt es nicht eine Tablette, wo einfach alles drin ist? So, ich nehme dann eine Brausetablette mit Calcium und denke mir, ja, jetzt fehlt mir aber Eisen. Muss ich dann beide nehmen? Also es ist so merkwürdig, warum man nicht einfach, und das gibt es in Amerika wahnsinnig viel, diese Ersatz, also Substitute Ernährung, egalweise mit so Gummibären, Vitamingummibären, jedes Vitamin der Welt, abnehmen, Pillen, alles und ich glaube, die sind ja eh ein bisschen laxer, was so Medikamente angeht, die man auch in grossen Dosen kaufen kann da und das ist schon abgefahren. Genau, Aspirin gibt es ja einfach in so riesen Paketen, die so acht Jahre halten. Ja, du hast den Vorrat gekauft. Habe ich nicht gekauft. Hast du nicht gekauft. Aber so ein riesen ... Ich denke immer, Aspirin ist auch gut gegen Kopfschmerzen. Man hat dann darauf auf gar keinen Fall für Kopfschmerzen geeignet, weil es sehr spät einsetzt.
Hab ich nicht ganz verstanden. War so ein Pain-Reliever, aber ich hab ihn nicht verstanden. Man merkt auch, dass Stefan langsam erwachsen wird, weil man kennt ja so dieses, man geht zusammen in einen Laden rein, in einen tollen neuen Laden und jeder geht so irgendwo hin und sucht und dann kommt man zurück und guck mal, guck mal, was ich gefunden habe und zeigt dir dann irgendwie so ein tolles Spielzeug oder Lego ATS-Z-Set und Stefan kommt, guck mal, guck mal, was ich gefunden habe und hat einfach so 400 Tabletten Aspirin, wo ich mir denke, guck mal, guck mal, das ist jetzt ein grosser Fund und eine Menge Aspirin-Tabletten. Genau, in der Hinsicht erwachsener geworden, aber danach legt er sie auch weg und kauft sie nicht. Ja, okay, gut, das hast du gut gemacht. Dankeschön, ich habe mich gefreut, die gefunden zu haben, auch trotzdem. Weil so ein Haufen, das sieht so verboten aus. Wenn du das alles nehmen willst, bist du tot. Ja, das sieht einfach nach Überdosis aus. Das sieht einfach aus, als würde man das einfach... Man kennt es nur von Bildern von Promi-Toten. Ja, genau. Wo das dann nachgestellt wird in Smarties. Ich nehme nur manchmal Vitamin C, weil ich von einem Formel-1-Fahrer gehört habe. Die wie gesagt, die besten Bestbezahlter sind Sportler und da stecken
bestimmt unfassbare Medizinergruppen
und
Forschung hinter, dass die
körperlich funktionieren und dann
nimmt einer immer Vitamin C. Und dann
ich mir, oh gut, dann muss ja was dran sein.
Also wenn ich mich... Wenn es für Hochleistungsformel-1-Sportler
gut ist, dann ist es für mich
auch gut auf deinem Bus-Support.
Ja genau, ich denke mir dann einfach, wenn ich mich entscheiden muss dann vor so einem Regal, dann würde ich mich eher für Vitamin C entscheiden. Aber hast du wieder einen neuen Mut geschöpft für dein Boosted Board? Weil wir haben jetzt in New York ein paar gesehen. Ich habe immer wieder neuen Mut gefunden, auch zu Hause schon. Ich bin immer noch, ich fahre mir noch gerne mit dem Boosted Board. Ja? Ja, in Köln tatsächlich nicht, in Köln bräuchte man eher das Mini, weil da hast du engere Wendekreise und so und da ist das grosse, weiss ich nicht, nicht so richtig geeignet für. Das ist eher cool, wenn nur auf leeren Landstrassen, in meiner Heimat ist das grosse Busselboard perfekt, aber in Köln bräuchte ich ja das kleine. Und in deiner Heimatball ist da so ein bisschen rum? Ja, auf jeden Fall, das Busselboard ist perfekt. Sieht man sehr viele Leute hier auch unterwegs, im Sandwich Park vor allem. Aber würdest du sagen, du beherrschst es mittlerweile auch gut und kannst so ein paar Tricks oder so? Was heißt Tricks? Beherrschen ist beim Boosted Board glaube ich nicht zu sterben. Bis jetzt gelungen. Es gibt auch immer so einen geilen Subreddit von Boosted, wo jeden Tag Bilder hochgeladen werden. Oh, heute Boosted-Board bekommen, nächsten Tag und gebrochener Ankle und gebrochenes Genick. Es ist wirklich gefährlich, weil es einfach Boosted ist. Ey, aber was ich hier auch ein paar Mal gesehen habe, waren diese elektromotorisierten Fahrräder. Und die sind ja wirklich todgefährlich. Ich wäre zweimal fast überfahren worden, weil du stehst an der Strasse und schaust nach links und rechts, kommt kein Auto und du siehst nach rechts in 100 Meter Entfernung ein Fahrrad. Und man hat einfach instinktiv... Und es sind diese Fahrräder, die sehen nicht aus wie Rennräder. Genau, das sind so Darmräder. Die haben diese, wir lehnen uns zurück, Haltung, sind aber arschschnell. Ja, und dein Gehirn hat abgespeichert, durchschnittliche Geschwindigkeit eines Fahrrads, kann ich ungefähr einschätzen, also gehe ich über die Strasse, weil der ist noch weit weg, gehe über die Strasse und du schaust nach rechts und der ballert wirklich mit Überschallgeschwindigkeit auf dich und du denkst, ist das eine Fata Morgana, so schnell kann der sich nicht bewegen und am Ende springe ich todesmutig zur Seite, weil der einfach so krass angeballert kommt, also wirklich Motorradgeschwindigkeit. Die gibt es in Berlin, die heissen Jump-Räder. Aber ich rede von einem Fahrrad. Ich weiß, die gibt es in Berlin, die heißen Jump-Räder von Uber. Die sind rot und sie sind so hollandartige Räder, also du kannst sie entspannt zurücklehnen und die haben drei Gänge und du gibst ein bisschen Gas und dann kickt der Elektromotor halt rein und beschleunigt dich einfach auf 40 kmh, unglaublich schnell. Und du hast diesen entspannten Fusstritt, dieses entspannte Radeln, aber bist einfach sauschnell und nichts an deiner Körperhaltung und sagst, ich rase gerade. Und dann war es halt in Berlin, das ist wirklich toll, weil du hast diese grossen, im Osten teilweise so ganz tolle, grosse Strassen mit grossen Radwegen. und du hast dann diese Rennradfahrer, Berliner Rennradhipster, die unfassbar schnell radeln und wo alles an dem Körper sagt, ich fahr gerade schnell und du fährst mit dieser entspannten Pose und deine Radbewegung sagt, ich fahr zwei kmh, aber fährst halt 50 an den vorbei und dann wollte ich einen mal überholen, aber die sind halt runtergeregelt und im gewissen Zeitpunkt sagen die, nö, das war es jetzt.
Und dann beschleunigen die nicht weiter, dann behältst du deine Geschwindigkeit bei.
Das heißt, und ich habe dann den so übermütig angegrenzt und habe den dann überholen wollen und dann habe ich Gas gegeben und genau in dem Moment, wo ich neben ihm war, hat mein Motor gesagt, nö, das war es jetzt. regelt runter und ich bin dann bestimmt zehn Minuten neben dem hergefahren, minimal schneller vielleicht. Aber ich konnte genau, beim Überholen muss man Gas geben, um dann vorbeizukommen, dann kann es wieder langsamer werden. Aber dieser Überholvorgang hat nicht funktioniert, weil genau dazwischen hat das Rad gesagt, nope, erinnert diesen arroganten, ich bin schneller als du Blick. Und du hast dieses arrogante Lächeln für zehn Minuten, so eh. Ja, genau, so beibehalten, verkrampft, aber dann irgendwann war ich dann vorbei. Die sind ganz toll. Aber warum muss man treten? Muss man treten oder ist das so Alibi-mäßig oder dass der Motor nicht ausgeht? Du musst schon treten, der springt erst dann an. Fragt mich nicht genau, wie das technisch funktioniert. Und du machst dann so 20 % und der Motor 80 % von der Leistung? Nee, ich glaube, du machst gar nicht. Aber er macht es aber gar nicht. 5 % machst du, du treibst du machst nur den Wäffel, das dein Motor an. Du bist sozusagen das Stromkabel für den. Krass. Ja, gut. Nächste Woche wieder eine ganz normale Folge. Ich melde mich aus dem Urlaub mal ab und zu. Vielen Dank, dass ihr bei uns wart und uns in New York begleitet habt. Falls Fragen offen geblieben sind, danke für eure ganzen Empfehlungen. Wir haben ein paar umgesetzt. Ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch an alle Gewinner des Buchs von Julia, das Gewinnspiel ist mittlerweile
BNDett. Ihr braucht keine weiteren Mails zu schreiben, die Gewinner sollten mittlerweile ihr Buch,
ich glaube, ich sage jetzt hier nochmal nichts. Ja, alles klar, das war's, haut rein, bis zum nächsten Mal.
WM-Up, macht's gut, ciao!